[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up proof
welcome walter hi martin
we're back to do part two
yes gospel of john yeah why are we
talking about the gospel of john
well we spoke about it last time because
it has a very particular message
about
the divinity of christ the centrality of
the gospel
and a special message for those that
will receive the outpouring of the rain
as a type of the latter rain yes
so it's a very important message
so let's open with the word of prayer
yes that will get right into it
our heavenly father
thank you thank you for everything that
you do for us thank you for bringing us
together again
and also
for
enabling us to have these discussions
will you bless this discussion enlighten
our minds with the holy spirit in jesus
name amen amen
john played such a pivotal role
he was as we said many times the son of
thunder
and then he became
this
meek but firm
as a rock to principle disciple
and
i don't think it's coincidental that the
lord gave him the revelation
on the isle of patmos
to link
the new testament prophecies to the old
testament prophecies
and you know martin
when i looked at
daniel and i read in selected messages
i found it very interesting that there
was another perspective
to this last verse
in the book of daniel chapter 12
where god says
what would happen at the end
so he gives a time prophecy
from verse 10 onwards 11 and 12 and then
he says but go thy way till the end be
for thou shalt rest
that means he will
be put to sleep
and stand in thy lot at the end of the
days
now
the way i always interpret it is that
there will be a resurrection and i think
that's correct there will be a
resurrection but there's another
application that i missed
he will stand in his lot or in his place
in the latter days
now that's very interesting
because
that means he will
fulfill a prophetic position in the last
days
because remember
that there was a portion of the book of
daniel the 2300 day prophecy that was
sealed unto the time of the end so
actually the book will also be standing
in its place book will be standing in
its place and then i read in selected
messages
and i found this so fascinating
you know
the bible is a marvelous book and the
spirit of prophecy is such a wonderful
help
i'm reading it from page 109
in selected messages book two
and it says all that god has in
prophetic history specified to be
fulfilled in the past has been
and all that is yet to come in its order
will be
daniel god's prophet stands in his place
that's in his lot
john stands in his place
in the revelation the lion of the tribe
of judah
has opened to the students of prophecy
the book of daniel
and thus daniel standing in his place
he bears his testimony that which the
lord revealed to him in vision of the
great and solemn events which we must
know as we stand on the very threshold
of their fulfillment
so here he stands
in his place
in other words
he fulfills a prophetic profile
and john and daniel
are to be linked together yeah
now the gospel of john tells the story
of jesus in a totally different way to
the other three gospels the synoptic
gospels and we discussed that last time
and then it has this information for
god's people that are going to be faced
with a crisis yes
and then you have
the epistles that john wrote 1 john 2
john 3 john and then the book of
revelation which links it all together
and it's fascinating to me
that when you study it and you study the
spirit of prophecy with it it tells you
quite clearly that the events that are
foretold for the time that we are living
in
have to do with the authority of god and
the law of god yes
now we spoke last time about the order
of the books and that the law
would be far more prominent if the order
had been retained
now the law of god of course is the
basis of his government
and the sabbath is the symbol of his
authority
to
wield
that authority and to
implement or to make it the basis of his
government and the devil is opposed to
it and he has an agent
and
as these messages were unfolded the
first second and third angels messages
as they unfolded in their time from 1843
to 1844 and onwards
they were
enlightened by the spirit of god
and the whole conflict
there was really
highlighted in the reformation
comes to its culmination in the book of
revelation
and we know
what the enemy of god is doing to get
rid of the basis of his government the
law yes
and
in john's time
you must also put it in perspective
the sabbath wasn't under attack no
because they were all the christians and
the jews were still keeping their real
sabbath yes so he didn't even know when
he was in revelation giving it that this
authority will be attacked yes that it
was going to be about the sabbath end
yes and the interesting thing is if you
if you're related back to the duty of
god's people in the end and why it's
important that we understand these
things then we must turn to asia chapter
because this relates this
the duty of god's people
so isaiah chapter 58 talks about a
people that will restore the old west
places
and uh it talks about the fast that god
requires
that changes the heart
and verse seven it says
or in verse six actually is this not the
fast that i have chosen
to lose the bands of wickedness
to undo heavy burdens and to let the
oppressed go free
and that you break every yoke
that is the purpose of evangelism
that's the purpose of it is it not to
deal thy bread to the hungry
now this is very important because we're
going to talk about
the gospel of john
and we will discuss certain issues there
where the bread becomes very important
in a spiritual sense
so if we read this spiritually is it not
to deal thy bread to the hungry
and that thou bring the poor that are
cast out of thy house
when thou seest the naked that thou
cover him
and that thou hide not thyself from
thine own flesh this is not only in a
physical sense
this is a spiritual sense in other words
the naked or those that are devoid of
the righteousness of christ yes and
those that are hungry are those that are
not being fed with the truths of the
gospel
of the word and the interesting thing is
it says many of them were cost out of
thy house
in other words god's own people trampled
on his
possession
and made their lives a misery
and there will be a gathering time and
god will set the record and bring them
back into bring them back that's
interesting um again
in the previous one we also mentioned
they're coming into the house
so nobody's leaving the house yes
so if you are saying you must leave
because the house has become
babylon well the house was corrupt
because many were cast out of the house
and many have been trampled upon but god
will gather them again he'll bring them
back into the house
and then verse 8
then shall thy light break forth as the
mourning and thine health shall spring
forth speedily and thy righteousness
shall go before thee
the glory of the lord shall be thy rear
ward this is such a wonderful promise
in other words you'll be surrounded by
the righteousness of christ and he will
go before you and he will be behind you
he will hit you in
then shalt thou call and the lord shall
answer and shall cry and he shall say i
am here here i am
if i take away from the midst of thee
the yoke
the putting forth of the finger
and speaking vanity you know people
place yokes on
on other people
by constantly criticizing
uh this is just the nature of humanity
it seems and place burdens upon them
that god never required
and you know one of the great burdens
that the jewish nation placed upon its
own people
were the exacting rules and regulations
particularly with regards to the sabbath
that's true
and if i draw out thy soul to the hungry
and satisfy the afflicted soul
then shall thy light rise in obscurity
and thy darkness be as the noon day
what a beautiful promise
so
no self-centered religion
can be
placed into this setting
so
how what was the character of the
leadership like
that god had to make a statement like
that they were boastful and proud and
full of themselves probably and then
this beautiful promise in verse 11 and
the lord shall guide thee continually
and satisfy thy soul in drought
and make fat thy bones and thou shalt be
like a watered garden
and like a spring of water whose waters
fail not
and they that shall be
of thee
shall build the old waste places
thou shalt raise up the foundation of
many generations thou shalt be called
the repairer of the breach the restorer
of paths to dwell in
martin who's he talking about here he's
talking about the remnant that will come
out there yes because
this is this is reminiscent of
revelation chapter 12 verse 17
come out of my people the remnant that
will remain and they that shall be of
thee
those that come forth out of this truth
they shall build the old waste places in
other words
many a truth has been buried in rubble
it's a wasted place it has to be
repaired
thou shalt raise up the foundations of
many generations
so martin even the foundation
has been destroyed
now what is the foundation
i will put enmity between thee and the
woman that was the first gospel message
ever preached
and
this gospel message
this everlasting gospel
must be restored
now the interesting thing is
the christian world today
has rejected the law of god
they pay it lip service sometimes
but they have basically made it null and
void right yes okay
but if the law is the basis
of god's government
then it cannot be made null and void and
it cannot be divorced from the gospel
because if you divorce the law from the
gospel then there is no need for christ
to die
that's exactly it
and like we've said before as well
the
fact that he died
proves that the law stands so you cannot
divorce the law it's the basis
of everything it's because the law was
transgressed
that death came into the world
that a savior was required
so
we have to restore those old waste
places and build up that foundation from
the ground up
many generations so it's not only this
generation that has lost the plot they
lost the plot throughout history
because there's an adversary
and then this
this people they shall be called the
repairer of the breach
the restorers of paths to dwell in
now a bridge a bridge was in the wall
now the wall always stood for the law
the wall of protection there was a
breach in it and then it has to give us
some details as to what that breach was
right
and verse 13 is actually in the original
a new paragraph
so let's read this this is the very
important
if they thou turn away thy foot from the
sabbath
from doing thy pleasure on my holy day
what is the lord's day
sabbath so how can the christian world
claim
that when
john
speaks about being envisioned on the
lord's day that that was sunday
it's incomprehensible it's
incomprehensible and it actually means
that
a little bit of a lack of study
because if you study this
you cannot go wrong you cannot go wrong
this is the only definition of what the
lord's day is because he says my holy
day
it's not our day
people always say
you keep your sabbath and i'll keep mine
and i say no no no i keep the lord's
sabbath you are keeping a human sabbath
and call the sabbath a delight the holy
of the lord honorable and shall honor
him not doing thine own ways nor finding
thine own pleasure nor speaking thine
own words
is it important
the sabbath
pivotal pivotal right
so
it's just a question of a day martin
no no no there's a much much deeper
meaning
everything hangs on it authority
let me just read that first section
again
if thou turn away thy foot
from the sabbath
now what do you do with your foot don't
you trample under foot
so in other words that
the sabbath will be trampled under foot
and if you stop doing that
stop trampling my sabbath underfoot
then what will be the consequences
then shalt thou delight thyself in the
lord
and i will cause thee to ride upon the
high places of the earth and feed thee
with the heritage of jacob thy father
now the heritage of jacob thy father is
eternal life
that's it
for the mouth of the lord has spoken it
so often can we divorce the law and
particularly the sabbath from the end
time message actually the sabbath
will
re-emphasize
the importance of keeping the whole law
all right and it also emphasizes the
relationship it is the breach in the
wall because it attacks the authority of
god and attacks the basis of his
government
jesus said
in the old testament in prophetic terms
i delight to do thy will
so this is this is a very pivotal
section it's also very pivotal the
delight
because
how many people say it's a burden the
sabbath
now let's just look at that one now
jesus
did he make
sabbath issues prominent in his ministry
definitely
like we've mentioned
the pool of batista
all of those miracles those seven
miracle sabbath miracles
and and they incense the jews
but here it says quite plainly you must
call the sabbath a delight now the one
who was healed
the one who was loosened from this yoke
of bondage
was he joyful on that day he leaped he
leaped right yeah who was miserable
the people that were that were keeping
sabbath
all right
but
on their terms let's put it in a modern
context
if you delight yourself in the sabbath
today who is miserable
the rest of the christian world the rest
of the christian world is miserable
nothing has changed
nothing has changed so we cannot divorce
this from our study of
what john has to say
right so we need to understand we need
to understand that john
is not only
lifting up christ
in the stories that he tells he is
lifting up the law
he's lifting up the sabbath
by relating what christ did on those
particular days loosening the yoke
and how you rebuke those
pharisees and say just think about it
this woman who has been suffering all
these years and you don't want to
release her from this yoke on the
sabbath day
unbelievable right
so you can have a right concept of the
sabbath you can have a wrong concept of
the sabbath you can have a right
understanding
of what true religion is and you can
have a wrong understanding
you can have a
a liberating view and you can have a
yoke view
it's been like that all along
so that brings us
now to our further study now last time
we also had this quote
so let's just put this quote there again
comes from the review and herald june 18
1901 the will of god in regard to his
people is plainly expressed in the 6th
13th
14th
15th
16th
and 17th chapters of john
the chapters after that deal with the
events of the crucifixion
but the instruction to god's people to
that group that was to receive the
former reign
we find it in
these chapters we need to understand the
6th the 13th the 14th the 15th the 16th
and the 17th chapter of john
this was when judas was already gone
like you've mentioned he lives in the
13th chapter yeah
so this is like you mentioned this is
for the disciples or for the end time
people only correct so martin this is
what we want to do in this study we want
to go through the 6th the 13th the 14th
the 15th the 16th and the 17th chapter
of john
and see
what instruction there is
for
god's
people
and this is the divine antidote for the
sin of the whole world which is
contained in the gospel of john that's a
powerful statement right
so is it important that we study it well
it's the antidote it's the antidote
who so eateth my flesh and drinketh my
blood christ declared has entered life
and i will raise him up at the last day
he may die
as christ died
but the life of the savior is in him his
life is hid with christ in god
i am come that they may have life jesus
said and that they may have it more
abundantly he carries on the great
process
by which believers are made one with him
in this present life to be one with him
throughout all
eternity
so let's turn to the gospel of john and
go to chapter six we came up to chapter
five
last time now why is chapter six so
important
well we just read what the task of god's
people is
at the end of time
it's to feed the hungry
and to share the bread right
so we need to understand what is meant
when we are to share the bread
so after these things jesus went over
the sea of galilee
which is the sea of tiberias and a great
multitude followed him
because they saw his miracles which he
did on them
that were diseased
and jesus went up into the mountain and
there he sat with his disciples
and the passover a feast of the jews was
nigh when jesus then lifted up his eyes
and saw a great company come unto him he
said unto philip
when shall we buy bread that these may
eat
now
just think in terms of the gospel
message
come
by
without price without money come buy
bread and wine
so we are dealing here with the gospel
message
so he's actually testing philip
he's saying to philip
where will we get bread for all of these
people
and of course they're thinking
uh
literally literally
and jesus is thinking spiritually he
wants to to give them a message
so it tells us this he said to prove him
for he himself knew what he would do
philip answered 200 penny worth of bread
is not sufficient for them that every
one of them may take a little
now a penny was a day's wages
so 200 days wages is not enough to feed
these people
one of the disciples andrew simon
peter's brother said unto him there's a
lad here
which has five barley loaves and two
small fishes
but what are they amongst so many
there's a lot of symbolism
in the barley loaves and the two small
fishes
now
bali
was
the early harvest
whit was
the late harvest
so
when it speaks about barley loaves we're
talking about the early reign
so there are five barley loaves
five is the number of humanity as we
said five senses and then there are two
small fishes
now a fish was the
the symbol of humanity that would be
caught by the net
right yeah
now there are two small fishes
now why two small fishes
the interesting thing is
what is catching them
the gospel the gospel is catching them
and where is the gospel written old and
new older than the new testament so
that's two portions right
so people look at this and they want to
make literal arguments about whether
it's right to eat fish or not this is
ridiculous we're dealing with a
spiritual issue here it's not a diet
plan no it's not a dietary plan here
so we're dealing with barley
loaves we're dealing with the outpouring
of the former rain
and what is applicable to the former
rain must also be applicable to the
latter rain
so i've got five here that's enough
for all of humanity
and there are two small fishes here
there are two
uh
things that have been brought into this
gospel
so let's talk about god's word and jesus
said make the men sit down
and there was much grass in the place so
the men sat down in numbers
about five thousand
again you have the number five
and jesus took the loves and when he had
given thanks he distributed to his
disciples and the disciples to them that
were sat down and likewise of the fishes
as much as they would
interesting right yeah there's always a
little twist there i love the way this
these things are written
okay so
here is a principle
in verse 11.
jesus took the loaves
and when he had given thanks he
distributed
to whom
to a disciple yes and they to the
okay so how does this work martin
so when it comes to
dealing out the spiritual bread
jesus will give you
what you need
if you
do the necessary preparation
and then it is your duty
to pass it on yeah okay that is the the
line of demarcation
so number one
jesus takes the loaves the bread
he gives things
he distributes to the disciples the
disciples to them which sat down and
likewise of the fishes as much as they
would
so you could take less or you could take
more right as much as they would choice
you have a choice
and when they were filled he said unto
the disciples gather up the fragments
that remain that nothing be lost
that's important right
nothing may be lost if you put it into
this spiritual
you you can get so much more then you
understand what he means okay so
something might be thrown down
but nothing will be lost
nothing
the god the word of god will not return
empty
and i think of these stories that are
often read
where you know people get angry and
there was a story about
a man in i think it was south america
who was angry with the bible
and he tore it up when he threw it into
the river
and downstream someone was catching fish
and he saw it and he picked up one leaf
after the other and he put it together
again yeah so that was nice
nothing was lost
therefore they gathered them together
and filled 12 baskets
how many disciples were there
12 12 twelve around one
all right so there was enough
for each of them to have a basket to
distribute yeah
were the fragments of the five barley
loaves which remained over and above
unto them that had eaten
then those men when they had seen the
miracle that jesus did said this is of a
truth that prophet that should come into
the world
when jesus therefore perceived that they
would come and take him by force to make
him a king he departed again into a
mountain himself alone so the people saw
this miracle said this must be the
messiah will make him king
again they had a wrong concept right
they wanted a
solution to their immediate problem
but they didn't necessarily want a
solution to the soul
it's pretty much where we are today
again
people want
an earthly
savior for an earthly kingdom they want
an earthly kingdom
it's interesting martin
that the very next story we don't have
to read at all
is uh
a very interesting one because
here he is walking on the sea
because they left in their boats
and
a great wind blew
and there was a storm upon the water
and then jesus came walking upon the sea
so he's the master of the sea
and he's the one that can calm the sea
but this is a this is the spiritual
story
of
the
storms
that will rage amongst humanity because
the waters stand for the peoples the
multitudes the nations
and here is one that is above the storm
he walks across the water
and then there's another little miracle
here when jesus said it is i
they willingly received him it says in
verse 21 into the ship and immediately
the ship was at land whether they went
here's another miracle right there were
a number of those miracles instant
transportation
how did we get here
and god will perform miracles
to help us to spread the gospel to
wherever it is needed
the next day martin
he again meets up with the people that
were involved in this great miracle of
the bread
and
they came to seek for him and he said
you know you come to seek me because you
were filled
with physical bread
and
there are many
so-called
loaves and fishes christians who are
there for the temporal advantages
but the deeper meaning often escapes
them
and so now we need to understand what
jesus has to say to them they say to
them how did you come here where did you
come from etc and jesus said
verse 26
verily verily i say unto you you seek me
not because you saw the miracles but
because you did eat of the loaves and
were filled
labor not for the meat for the food
which perishes but for that meat which
endureth unto everlasting life
which the son of man shall give unto you
for him has got the father sealed
interesting right
then they said unto him what shall we do
that we might work the works of god is
that an important question
definitely
jesus answered and said unto them this
is the work of god that you believe on
him whom he has sinned
so if you believe in christ
then you will be empowered
to do the works of god
because then you will want to be
transformed right
and what is the work of god works of god
it is to hand out
the bread to the other people why did
jesus come to this world to seek this
and save the lost right
and uh he shares that because he hands
it to the disciples and the disciples
are supposed to hand it to the other
people
it's amazing that they then ask him what
signs show us thou then that we may see
and believe thee
what
does
thou work
it's amazing just just the previous day
showed them
physically
and now they don't understand it all
right now here is the crux of the matter
they say to him our fathers
did eat manna
in the desert as it is written he gave
them bread from heaven to eat
and now comes the spiritual application
then jesus said unto them verily verily
i say unto you
moses gave you not that bread from
heaven but my father gives you the true
bread from heaven
for the bread of god is
he
not it he
it is a person
the bread of god is he which cometh down
from heaven and giveth life unto the
world
so the gospel is personified
it is in a person
then they said unto him lord evermore
give us this bread and jesus said to
them i am the bread of life
he that cometh to me shall never hunger
and he that believeth in me shall never
thirst those are two powerful promises
now if you were to take them literally
then you would be disappointed right
because there will be times when you
will be hungry
and there will be times when you will be
thirsty but this spiritual food and
spiritual drink
is for all eternity
but i said unto you
that ye also have seen me and believe
not all that the father giveth me
shall come to me
and him that cometh to me i will
in no wise cast out that's an amazing
promise
in other words seek and you will find
for i came down from heaven not to do my
own will but the will of him that sent
me
and this is the father's will which has
sent me that of all which he has given
me i should lose nothing
but should raise it up again in at the
last day
so all that come to christ
with penitent hearts
and hunger and thirst shall be filled
and they shall be filled with the he not
with the it
and they will be raised up at the last
day
and this is the will of him that sent me
that everyone which sees the son and
believeth him
may have everlasting life and i will
raise him up at the last
day
so how does this work
believe
that means by faith
so righteousness is by faith but that
wasn't acceptable to them
they wanted righteousness by works
but now they ask them what are your
works
and they receive an answer that they
don't like
because the answer is you have to
believe
they want to hear something that they
must do
correct just give me a recipe and i'll
bake the cake
but they don't get a recipe you have to
believe
now this this believing of course
doesn't mean that you don't have to obey
the world because jesus himself said i
came to do the will of him who sent me
you see if you put the faith in the
right
position
then the other will follow
absolutely correct
so what did they do when he said this
this is amazing
so faith in other words doesn't negate
works but as you said they must be in
the right sequence right
and they are
ensconced in an individual who is christ
so verse 41 is rather surprising the
jews then murmured at him
they weren't happy with that right
uh is the christian world today happy
with that no if you
they happy with their version of it so
didn't the largest so-called christian
denomination call it an anathma
to believe that the righteousness of
christ comes by faith alone
so they murmured at them because he said
i am the bread which came down from
heaven
and they said is this not jesus the son
of joseph
whose father and mother we know how is
it then that he said i came down from
heaven
and jesus therefore answered and said
unto them murmur not amongst yourselves
no man
can come to me except the father which
has sent me draw him and i will raise
him up at the last day that's the third
time it made that promise
three times three times and the
sadducees couldn't have been happy with
that either right because they didn't
believe in the resurrection
it is written in the prophets and they
shall be
all taught of god
now prior
the gospel was administered by angels so
said paul in the book of hebrews
now they will be taught of god so who
was standing in front of them god god
every man therefore that has heard and
has learnt of the father cometh unto me
not that any man has seen the father
save he which is of god he has seen the
father
verily i say unto thee i say unto you he
that believeth on me has everlasting
life
what an amazing promise eh
i am the bread of life your fathers did
eat manna in the wilderness and are dead
this is the bread that comes down from
heaven that the man may eat thereof and
not die i am the living bread which came
down from heaven if any man eat of this
bread he shall live forever
and the bread that i give is my flesh
which i will give for the life of the
world
here he declares himself god again yes
absolutely i am that bread i am that
living bread
and then the jews
strove amongst themselves saying how can
this man give us his flesh to eat
so they refused to make the spiritual
application
they were thinking cannibalistically
so then jesus said unto them verily i
sound to you except you eat the flesh of
the son of man and drink the blood ye
have no life in you
who so eateth my flesh and drinketh my
blood has eternal life and i will raise
him up at the last day there's the
promise again
so flesh
is death
but blood is life because the life is in
the blood so christ gives his
blood
so that we might have life
and he dies in the flesh
to be raised up into eternal life and
because we believe in him
we can be raised up with him if we are
prepared to die to self
that is what it amounts to
now martin what does this
mean that
you must eat the flesh he says in verse
55 for my flesh is meet indeed and my
blood is drink indeed and he that eateth
my flesh and drinketh my blood dwelleth
in me and i in him
as the living father has sent me
and i live by the father so he that
eateth me even he shall
live by me this is that bread which came
down from heaven not as your fathers did
eat manna and not dead he that eaters of
this bread shall live
forever
now let's just get
another verse in the bible to bring this
into some context
i want to read jeremiah 15 verse 16
thy words were found
and i did eat them
thy word was unto me the joy and
rejoicing of my heart
for i am called by thy name o lord god
of hosts
just mull that one over
let's just turn back to the very first
verse in the gospel of john
and we should all
know that one
in the beginning was the word
and the word
was with god
was god
and the word here in my bible in the
king james is capitalized
so in the beginning was the word and the
word was with god and the word was god
jeremiah said thy words were found and i
did eat them and thy word was unto me
the joy and rejoicing of mine heart for
i am called by thy name o lord god of
hosts
so what is
the purpose of eating
the flesh of the son of god and drinking
the blood internalizing his word
internalizing his word now martin
in today's world
people are inclined to
rely on experience
experiential religion
feel good yes feel good religion not
only that
i am led by the spirit
now the spirit never works separate from
the word of god
if you take catholicism
believes in the spiritual exercises of
ignatius lyola which is totally divorced
from the word because it is based on a
spiritual experience now let's rephrase
that a spiritualistic
experience
which could be the voice of demons it is
because if you go to the
in the past there's been
situations like in 1988 those people
that had for five years all these
experiences with angels and eventually
the angels told them to get
rid of some of the other members in
their bible study group yes
because they were a threat
to the group
so you can be so indoctrinated by an
experience that you even think that
murdering somebody can be good well
doesn't the bible say that eventually
this power that is called babylon
will turn upon god's people and make
laws to eradicate them
yeah isn't that exactly the same thing
that is going to happen on a universal
scale that happened here in a mini scale
exactly and they are going to think that
by experience they're doing the will of
god they're doing god the favor so let's
make it quite plain and stated
categorically
if you want to
eat the flesh and drink the blood in
other words if you want to internalize
the life of christ and his character in
you
where must you start
yeah in the word in the word all right
what was
the battle about
in the reformation
about the word of god about the word of
god
the war raged about the word of god it
was a conflict
between
the flesh and the blood of christ the
word of god
internalizing the word of god a thus
says the lord
as opposed to
human laws
and traditions and then it's so
important
okay to just reiterate
the real truth the real word of god
that's why we always bring up these
episodes that just have to put it back
into now the people the people in the
time of christ wanted signs and wonders
and jesus said you will have no miracles
no signs except the sign of jonah
you will see there was a death and there
was a resurrection that's the sign of
jonah
right he was in the belly of the of the
ground and he rose from the dead
so here in the end
we will only have one safe god
and that is the word of god yeah
we dare not trust our feelings no we
dare not trust our emotions emotions are
fine in their right place
if they're an outflow of your ex as long
as it's in harmony with the words this
is the basis this was the basis of
martin luther
if it wasn't in the scripture
then he was not going to be convinced
and he said it is not good
to go against your conscience
so if you have a religion that is
experiential
that tells you
that the spirit tells you that something
can be done that is contrary to this
word then it is a lying spirit
if the christian world says
that the sabbath is not important then
the bible just told us that how
important it is then it is a lying
spirit
so this is very very important issue now
can you see why chapter 6 is so
important
takes us back to the word
takes you back to where your basis has
to come from
your anchor is in the word
which reflects
jesus
yes
now interesting martin
that the the people that listened to
this they weren't overly excited right
and so we read in verse 59 these things
said he in the synagogue as he taught in
capernaum
many therefore of his disciples when
they heard this said this is a hard
saying who can bear it and when jesus
knew himself that his disciples murmured
at it he said unto them does this offend
you
what and if you shall see the son of man
ascend up where he was before it is the
spirit that quickeneth the flesh
profiteth nothing
the words that i speak unto you they are
spirit and they are life the words that
i speak to you
the bible the word of god
old testament the gospel in type and
shadows the new testament the gospel in
verity
and the result is verse 66 and from that
time many of the disciples went back and
walked no more with them
button another question
how many people
in today's world
when you confront them with the issues
in the word
do the same thing from that day
they walk no more on this road
and it is a hard thing it is our thing
and the problem is
they go back to a road that they think
is the one leading to the to heaven yes
but it doesn't
because there's only one way
and he's the way the truth and the life
and his words are the ones that ought to
determine what is the way of truth and
life
that's so important
so no
pastor no
nothing else but the word of god
jesus tells you what he requires of you
correct
then said jesus unto the twelfth
will he also go away
and simon peter answered him lord to
whom shall we go thou has the words of
eternal life
and we believe and are sure that thou
art the christ the son of the living god
and jesus answered them have not i
chosen you twelve and one of you is a
devil
he spoke of judas iscariot
the son of simon
for he it was that should betray him
being one of the twelve
so
at this point
the disciples say there is no other way
where shall we go
you have the words of eternal life what
there's no other way it's either that or
death that's how important the choice is
and one of them is the devil
so we can expect some fireworks
in the times that are ahead
so that's the basis of chapter six and
why it is so important
and why here at the end we need to be
word-based we need to understand the
mission
we need to understand isaiah 58 we need
to understand
daniel's prophecy in relation to the
prophecies in
revelation
and we need to find these things from
the word
and not from
some human devising
show me
in the word
right martin we're not going to go into
any great detail in the other chapters
we want to come to the crux of the
message which is chapter 13. just
interesting things in chapter 7.
in verse 17 jesus says if any man will
do his will
he shall know of the doctrine whether it
be of god or whether i speak of myself
it's a very interesting statement if any
man will do his will
he shall know of the doctrine
so is it a prerequisite
if you want to understand
the doctrine of christ and the doctrine
of salvation
is obedience a prerequisite yes if any
man will do his will then you'll
understand then you will understand the
doctrine that's when the doors open and
that's the thing so once you once you
continually criticize for instance the
sabbath
if you start keeping it
you will see it differently
yes
that's what he's promising you here
so give it a chance give it a chance
chapter eight deals with
the adulteress
and that's also an interesting
very interesting
little chapter
because
spiritual adultery
is is a very prominent factor amongst
people that profess to be followers of
christ right and followers of god
so here is a
fascinating
portion of scripture where these people
bring this woman caught in the very act
and a woman spiritually speaking is a
church right yeah
and jesus writes in the sand
it's fascinating to me that nowhere do
you ever read that jesus wrote something
except with his finger right yes
now where did he write with his finger
before on the
tables of stone on the tables of stone
so you know all of these fine little
nuances martin
people who say that this is
this is a human book of human devising
nobody
nobody can think up all of these
fine little connections it is an
inexhaustible book
and
what was the attitude of the woman that
was caught in adultery
she had repentance she was
she was remorseful yeah and she was
quiet and she was humble and she knew
that she was guilty
and he forgave her
and he said go and sin no more so you
know there's hope and there's this such
beautiful things
chapter 9 to me is also a very
fascinating chapter
where this man who was born blind and
was blind from birth
was
healed
and you know this is such a
fascinating chapter
and the disciples asked who has sent
this man
or his parents
we always want to find the blame right
why did this thing happen to you
etc and jesus says neither had this man
sinned nor his parents
but that the works of god should be made
manifest in him
i must work the works of him that sent
me
while it is day the night cometh when no
man can work as long as i am in the
world
i am the light of the world and then he
does something fascinating
when he had spoken he spat on the ground
and made clay
of the spittle and he anointed the eyes
of the blind man with the clay
and said unto him
go
wash in the pool of siloam which is by
interpretation
sent
that's fascinating again
like the bread that was given to the
disciples and then to the multitude
so the works of god were to be made
manifest in him
and then you must go all right now
here's a very interesting
nuance
he made clay yeah
and he anointed the eyes
because the man was blind now
we think spiritually it was also
spiritually blind
and
then it applies to all of us
because all of us are spiritually blind
from birth
now
when did he mold clay on a previous
occasion
at the creation of adam of adam
doesn't the bible say all things were
created by him and without him was not
anything created
so who was the creator jesus
and he took clay
and that was the original creation of
humanity
now he takes clay again
and he anoints the eyes
that's a symbol of recreation
so here's the creator god
taking clay
and
anointing the eyes in other words
recreating the spiritual eyesight
and he sends him to a
pool which is called salaam which means
to be sent
in other words he was to be a messenger
now who was he sent to
because it said to him go to the pool of
siloam and wash
so you have to have spiritual eyesight
you need to have a recreation and then
you need to wash
you have to you have to you had a mini
baptism that's it
you have to
wash away you have to
die that old death and have a
resurrection and then like the woman in
the previous chapter
go and sin no more go and sin no more
even though this wasn't because of his
sin that he was blind yes and so he was
sent to the pharisees right
and they were overjoyed to see a man
that had been bought
born blind
that he should now suddenly see
and come and teach them something
were they overjoyed no not at all they
were furious
absolutely furious wasn't this done on
the sabbath as well yes
now this miracle martin was obviously
done on the sabbath day because in verse
16 they say therefore said some of the
pharisees this man is not of god because
he keepeth not the sabbath day others
said how can a man that is a sinner do
such miracles
and there was a great division amongst
them what does the message
that
people are sent with that is rooted
in the bible
create great division
yep how many lives have been lost
because of this message
and so they wouldn't believe him and so
they called his parents
and his parents were afraid of them so
they said why don't you ask him so they
asked him again
they shouted him are you trying to teach
us
this man was a sinner and he says
whether he was a sinner or not
i cannot tell one thing i know i was
blind and now i see
and they were
furious
so the man answered and said unto them
verse 30
why herein is a marvelous thing that you
know not from whence he is and yet he
has opened up mine eyes
now we know that god heareth no sinners
but if any man be a worshiper of god and
do with his will
he may heareth
since the world began was it not heard
that any man opened the eyes of one that
was born blind if this man were not of
god he could do nothing
and they answered and said that
thou wasted altogether born in sin then
does thou teach us
[Music]
martin do we have similar situations
where people suddenly discover truth in
the world and they go to the minister
and the pastor and they say to him well
what do we do about
this and they say
who are you are you educated in the
schools of well did you study greek and
hebrew and did you do all of these
things
do you want to come and teach us now
you're not a theologian nothing has
changed
nothing has changed
and then it says they cast him out
all right
let's draw a parallel
in the times that we are living in if
you go
and you confront someone with the word
of god
and
they refuse to listen to it
if the blindness has been taken away and
you are sent with the message
the likelihood that they will cost you
out is very high it is
because they cast out jesus as well so
they will cost you out okay
so they would not accept the correction
they said dost thou teach us
then jesus heard that they had cast him
out and when he had found him he said
unto him dost thou believe in the son of
on the son of god
it's an interesting question so just
let's just recap there
did this man at any stage up until this
point see jesus no
no no he did not even know
who was the man but he received a
spiritual eyesight he became a witness
for christ
he started witnessing then he was cast
out now he could have felt very rejected
did jesus leave him in that state no
he came and met him right there there's
a beautiful promise there right so when
this happens to you
then jesus will come to you and he say
does thou believe
on the son of god
and he answered and said who is he lord
that i might believe on him and jesus
said unto him thou hast both seen him
and it is he that talketh with thee
that's pretty straight
in other words martin if you have
received your spiritual eyesight
and you are prepared to witness on
behalf of what you have received
and you receive persecution as a
consequence
will you then see
christ yes he will
reveal himself to you will reveal
himself
didn't it say that
if you do the will of god you will know
of the doctrine that's it
and he said lord i believe and he
worshipped him so what must jesus be if
he worshipped him
god correct only god only god so how is
it possible
that in this world that we are living in
people deny the divinity of christ
unbelievable right it's unbelievable but
it's
they don't want
what god what he is providing yeah they
want what they want
now this issue
of jesus being god is highly contested
in the world today
but it is very clear in the gospel of
john
and it is reiterated over and over and
over again did jesus rebuke this man
before you because you worshiped him no
not at all in fact just before that
he says it is i you you've seen him and
it is him speaking to you yes
so
jesus is in the fullest sense god
chapter 10 there is a dispute or
discussion between jesus and
the jewish people
and it says in verse 17 therefore does
my father love me because i lay down my
life that i
may take it up again
no man takes it from me but i lay it
down of myself
i have power to lay it down
and i have power to take it again this
commandment have i received of my father
must he be god in order to do that it
can only be god okay
then he says it quite plainly
says in verse 30
i and my father are one
then the jews took up stones again to
stone him jesus answered the many good
works have i showed you
from my father for which of these works
do you stone me
and the jews answered him saying for a
good work we stone thee not but for
blasphemy and because that thou being a
man make us thou selves god maketh
thyself god
so did they understand what jesus was
saying yes they were not they
acknowledged that he
mentioned that he is god he is god and
they understood it as such
and they denied it right
so this required
one
final
super proof
that they could not deny
he said i am the resurrection
i lay down my life i take it up again i
and the father are one
and
they were furious because he was making
himself god
and then in chapter 11 you have the
story of the resurrection of lazarus
this is
indisputable proof
that he is
god because he is the one who calls
lazarus forth out of the grave
and what did the jews
want to do to lazarus as a consequence
then they wanted to kill him as well now
does that surprise you
no
as soon as you
do the will of god and you acknowledge
that jesus is god satan wants to kill
you as well
so this is a pattern that we find in
humanity
we find this pattern that there is a
resistance to the truth
and particularly a resistance to the
truth as it is in jesus
and you can take all the big religions
of the world
catholicism denies the atonement
islam denies the atonement
the jews deny the atonement
and the other religions of the world
have no need of an atonement
so the big
issue is really the position of jesus
christ
that's it
it's always been even
the great controversy started like that
in heaven
that was the big final proof that jesus
gave
of his power
and his divinity
and the lesson
is there for all to study
and now we come to the portion
where jesus is about to depart from this
world
and he has a final message of
instruction for his disciples
a very
important message for their ears only
and it starts with the story of the last
supper which we read about in chapter 13
and then judas departs
and then in chapters 14
to 17
we have this final instruction which we
need to internalize
we need to eat this flesh and drink this
blood so that we can stand in the days
that are coming
so this important issue
we will discuss in our
next episode yeah yeah so we'll
definitely have
because it's going to take quite a time
yes
because this is so important this is
very important this has got to do with
what we are going through right now and
this message is for us correct just as
much as it was for the disciples
so let's close them with the word of
prayer
heavenly father
you have given us the words of life you
have told us to internalize them
to eat the flesh and to drink the blood
and lord if we do thy will you have
promised that we shall know of the
doctrine
we also pray that you will anoint our
eyes with clay
and recreate our spiritual eyesight
which has been blind from birth
we thank you lord that you are the
resurrection and the life
and that you are who you claim to be
and that it is right
for us to worship you
bless us as we go our way and be with us
as we come together again to discuss
this great plan of salvation in jesus
name amen
[Music]
so
you